this is Blackpool it's what
this is blackpool's restaurant of the
Year
never call out the orders yeah but I
mean I'm struggling in my own mind at
the minute no no really this is
blackpool's ration of the Year table two
two moves
I'm [__] I'm destroyed yeah that's
how I feel
I failed not to run a restaurant
[Music]
clunker [__]
Blackpool is Britain's biggest and
brasses Resort home to the nation's
favorite sealless comedians and an
unprecedented choice of chip shops love
it or love it this place doesn't do
anything by halves used to come to life
all the time with mum and dad in fact
this time of year to come and have a
look at the lights and um as long as you
go and play Bingo would you believe
same traps same light same noise
and same freezing weather [__] it's cold
catering for the massive 12 million
tourists that come here every year there
are more than 650 places to eat and I'm
looking for the one that's been crowned
and Blackpool tourist board ration of
the year
[Music]
can't be it
actually looks like a sex shop
having co-managed a restaurant in the
local casino 46 year old Dave Jackson
and 30 year old partner Dawn Brinley
pulled their life savings to offer
Blackpool a unique Oasis of home-cooked
Cuisine it's got a cracking atmosphere
when there's people in it it's lovely
and I love it and
to see empty we did it last an hour
stood here for three hours and I just
could have gone home in tears 18 months
later they're barely breaking even with
turnover at a poultry 500 pounds a week
we won an award we've got pretty good
reviews
but we still can't get people up the
stairs it's very depressing putting food
fresh food in the bin after two or three
days it's only the ground floor greasy
spoon that's stopping them from going
under
morning
Club one this is it upstairs first floor
Russian of the Year yes sir
Club ways upstairs restaurant dawn looks
after the front of house and comes up
with the menu ideas while Dave rustles
them up in the third floor kitchen
hi Gordon so
this is it yeah
thanks
pudding popular very popular
occasionally uh I forget about them
oh [__] yeah and the most popular dishes
on the menu what are they main course is
chickens popular yep Lamb's quite
popular this sounds intriguing flakes
salmon with strawberries
lemon and lime and honey dressing yeah
soup at the moment what does that mean
soap in the moment it's whatever
whichever one we do rather than put on
an actual soup so I mean we do tomato
and Cointreau at the moment we've got
tomato and contrite Jesus where did that
one come from so again that's it don't
come out I came up with the tomato and
she added the Cointreau so yeah it works
well does it yeah it flies out in order
for me to get up to speed yeah I'd like
to eat off it okay no problem I'll see
you in five
that I wasn't expecting because
nothing's on
the start of I've ordered one of day's
favorite dishes thank you a salad of
salmon and strawberries with a lime and
honey dressing no one's ever been in my
kitchen
and now I'm cooking for Gordon Ramsay
and my fingers won't work my brain won't
work what can I do a three-course meal
at clubway costs between 20 and 25
pounds there we go and pray for that
price in Blackpool Dane's food can't
afford to be anything less and perfect
thank you very much
[Music]
what was going through somebody's mind
putting salmon with strawberries
that can go off the end of the pier
next
I always think it was bad cooking for
the Mother-in-law it stays clearly out
of practice
but then this place is like the Mary
Celeste
okay just explain what it is please okay
we've got medallions of pork on a bed of
spring onion mashed potato the sauce is
Brie and nectarine and we have parsnip
crisps and compliments oh paprika hot
thank you
very tough the pork
it's been battered
and beaten heavily you struggle to give
that to a dog bits of parsnip
rubber they're supposed to be crisps by
the way
a brilliant nectarine sauce
yes
[__] disgusted
we'll skip the pudding
time for a debrief
I just hope Dave and Dawn have got
stronger stomachs than I have
[Music]
okay
we need to talk okay
I didn't expect it to be that bad
because everything was rough yeah trust
me the combination of a hot pre
nectarines and whiskey that's probably
the worst Source I've ever tasted in my
entire life
overcooked in separate pork
and badly put together
right okay yeah so work to do a lot of
work to do okay
by the way
the mash wasn't bad
one
I can't cry
how this place ever won anything other
than a [__] booby prize I'll never
know and if there was a rule book this
place would be the classic example on
how not to run a [__] restaurant
starting with rule number one don't
assume winning an award means people
will know who you are and where you are
way 41 is is Black blackpool's version
of the Year nah no it's around here just
off the Promenade
hello mate is blackpool's sort of
restaurant of the year
The Hot Spot since when you this year in
fact ladies have you heard of clubway 41
a restaurant
nobody seems to have even heard of the
place is blackpool's rational of the
Year
oh God but remarkably it seems the award
really is genuine
I've just found the forms for the
nomination for the Blackpool tourism
awards some of the best fresh food we've
ever eaten very many occasion for most
tastes yeah I'll say taste from a
[__] cow's backside to a pig's
[__] snort I would honestly say this
has been the best meal I've ever had in
my life honestly in Brackets
a truly Unforgettable experience well
[__] me I've had an unforgettable
experience eye-catching Decor someone's
pulling my [__] plonker
[Music]
yesterday I spent my first day at
clubway 41. blackpool's failing ration
of the year
quite frankly I don't know where to
start
next week
[Music]
Dave and Dawn have already lost two
houses in an effort to stay afloat and
if they're not careful they'll lose
their last remaining lifeline
the downstairs greasy spoon that's just
about keeping their bank manager at Bay
I was trying to find somebody
it's one of those days where I really
just want to be somewhere else today
it's time to bring Dave Dawn and their
food back to the real world how you
feeling this morning
totally destroyed
um
listen you've got to bounce back yeah
and I I ate that food last night and I
was honest I'm [__] I'm destroyed
yeah that's how I feel I feel like I
never want to [__] cook again you're
a tough cookie and you're resilient and
you've been through the mill before and
you know what's good and what's bad I'm
here to help
and I'm not going until I get it right
okay I'll take the [__] [__] yeah
but bounce back oh well I will
if he thinks that's pressure well wakey
wakey mate get a grip look for your
bollocks and once you found them then
start using them
they seem [__] cool so far
in order for me to really see
what you're like and understand your
capabilities I've got 20 people coming
for lunch today
okay now yep okay um they've got to be
in and out in an hour and a half they're
coming at two o'clock
it's been a long time since Dave had 20
customers to cook for and he's clearly
petrified
so I'm hoping to enlist the health of a
man who's been coping aberly with
pressure since I arrived
Nigel the short order cook and the cafe
downstairs
[Music]
um so when you get a rush on you how
many orders come on at once
uh well the cafe could be empty at one
stage then all of a sudden it can be
full there are 12 tables and you're on
your own and how many customers have you
done one day at Max what's the what's
the most you're going back 250 300 easy
and that's on a good Saturday yeah it's
busy yes very much so yeah oh yeah
yeah the Buzzy adrenaline is amazing two
minutes for the breakfast place
Nigel may spend most of his days cooking
bacon Butters but I wouldn't mind
betting as a solid man to have by your
side
especially when you're as gitri as Dave
is I've got a problem with
with the brilliant nectarine sauce I
haven't got any nectarines right Canal
well have you ever tasted it without the
nectarines no I've ever tasted it with
just a simple gravy yes fresh Rosemary
so forget the Brie sauce right okay yeah
that's fine as a 46 year old Chef day's
naivety is beginning to shock me I'm
gonna start off with a quick red wine
sauce but it turns out he's hardly set
foot in a kitchen since he trained in
the 70s
all I did was just crush it lightly
just for the hero of the night exactly
that how not to run a restaurant rule
number two never appoint yourself head
chef if you can't cook when we bought
this place to save on money you know I
took the roll of up here and then Dawn
we know it was perfectly capable of
running the restaurant
where does Dawn get these ideas from
vivid imagination
geez I mean a lot of the stuff she does
come up with certainly last year I mean
it worked and it worked well you know
we've got no customers yeah I know well
yeah so how did it work did it work for
you did it work for her because it
didn't work for the restaurant no yeah
all right I can't win that argument
because I got an empty restaurant
that's what that's what the flavor is
Hindi
[Music]
our 17 customers are local dancers
who've hot footed in here in between
shows they need to be in and out within
an hour and a half
the food's prepped and the restaurants
only half full and with Niger by his
side Dave should be able to cope thank
you sir I need to see the kitchen under
pressure
so I know he's your boyfriend yeah yeah
but give him some work to do bring him
on
are you ready to order no I'd put me
three inches of water in the bottom of
that mate
dealing with several orders at a time is
standard practice in the kitchen
but within seconds of receiving the
first Bunch Dave's flapping about like a
headless chicken
yeah okay darling right you've just put
me four checks in yeah who's in first
okay yeah they're both coming together
we've got both the checks at the same
time big deal
and whilst he's been panicking about the
orders Dave's burnt the custard
so that's on that's on the chicken did
you call out the orders Dave sorry if
you ever call out the orders yeah but I
mean I'm struggling in my own mind at
the minute so I won't how not to run a
restaurant rule number three if you lose
all powers of communication under
pressure
you shouldn't even be in the kitchen
they get clammed up you talk to him tell
him what you want him to do I'm not sure
sorry I'm not sure myself so it's your
[__] restaurant I know it's right
right give me a piece of pork
nice eggs baby look in the [__] already
I am yeah
the Customs have been here 27 minutes
and they still haven't had a sniff of
grunt
okay I'm gonna be nearly ready to go in
a minute on the first table Yeah
[Music]
the food has finally started to leave
the kitchen
[Music]
the weather is edible or not is another
matter
it's depressing
they're cooking for a dining room that's
only half full but for Chloe to survive
it needs to be completely chocker at
weekends
very difficult to keep people persuaded
when you're not following anyone
okay
it's been a long time oh no it's hard so
I'm getting no feedback from dawn so I'm
like I'm running blind Running Blind at
the minute what feedback do you need
right now well really is everybody okay
is anyone you know
starting to sort of like whinge because
they're waiting or inside
all over the shop like a [__]
orangutan and I'll just cool down and
just relax and get yourself proposed
yeah yeah I know yeah you're right yeah
yeah without getting paranoid yeah our
guests have to leave in 15 minutes and
they haven't even started on dessert
ships
[Music]
on it there you go right table seven
four mix have I got it yeah
Russian of the Year Blackpool yeah [__]
all over here um yeah making hard work
and nothing working all over the place
uh completely disorientated his own
kitchen very bad at delegation and
totally in a mess I can't think of two
things at once 17 guests that's all it
took him one hour and five minutes to
cook for 10 people and the last seven
guests had taken 45 minutes
shocking so you want three first one
bananas well I was asking you okay
that's fine right tell me that in the
first place
oh dear oh dear
six spare room again sorry
it's the end of the season for Blackpool
tomorrow night the illuminations will be
switched off and the tourists will go
home from what I've seen so far it will
be a miracle if clubway 41 survives the
winter
right Dave
stop cooking like a ray of time
stop lunking around
and bananas are off the menu
thank you very much thank you
by day three it's clear in my mind that
there's only one way forward simplify
the food and simplify the preparation
but first I want to give Dave a Nigel
senses a wake-up call get those on yeah
got to really rely on your taste buds
now how not to run a restaurant rule
number four if your chefs can't
distinguish between Heavenly and hellish
food combinations then your customers
won't be coming back for more Dave what
can you taste there
basil what about something meaty
start very rare beef
wash my fingers please
remember this one Dave's signature dish
even my six-year-old daughter would know
this as a country Calamity Dave told me
about that one what flavors can you
identify straight away
yeah pineapple yeah pineapple cheese I
think what it is
it like a shellfish like a scholar
when you brush your teeth in the morning
do you use toothpaste for cigarettes
because you've got a mouth like a cow's
backside
they're right there
good
Olive
tomato do those flavors work together
yeah they definitely work together yeah
one of my favorites
yeah ready for the last one the evil
salmon and strawberry starter open why
that Dave swears is so popular on his
menu first of all nice would you be
happy to pay money for that
no not this no on that one I wouldn't
not to my church no it doesn't work for
me it doesn't work nectarine or pork
okay take the [__] blindfolds off it
was that last stick
had your salmon and strawberries and
[__] Watercress on there
yes yeah if it doesn't work in your
[__] palette what chance has it got
working in a restaurant
point taken very much so yeah very
constructed that
dear oh dear oh dear now I need to be
sure the creative Mastermind behind
clubway's disastrous current menu Isn't
about to sabotage a painfully slow
progress
my question is what gives you the right
to think of these ideas and then in your
own mind think that is right for the
customers when you haven't seen it
before just experiment really just try
and put different flavors together we've
tried because we've tried so many menus
and try and fill the restaurant we have
done plain and then we've gone the
Avenue well maybe
um we are too plain and people can make
this at home and unfortunately it's not
working no I mean until you've actually
put it as plainly as you have done
yesterday and today and actually gone
through there's too many flavors going
on because the business is integrated
and there's no customers you're digging
deep but you're Lively you're a live
wire and that's a healthy sign in a
business you know it needs that energy
but I think what you've got to really
understand what you're telling Dave to
do he's not capable of doing right
the restaurant is empty and the next
stage is to close it we're not going to
close it we're going to look at clever
simple combinations put them back on the
menu
and get back to something that sounds in
touch with Blackpool
Club ways food isn't just unappetizing
it's packed with costly out of season
ingredients that reflect in its
overpriced menu
because I could use anything on it
didn't he
I've decided to challenge Dave's
perception of Simplicity by giving him a
tray full of ingredients to make a
broccoli soup he can use as many or as
few as he sees fit but it's got to be
good
okay is it finished yeah
should we taste broccoli I can taste
little bits of broccoli tell you it's a
[__] but you can't taste the flavor
exactly what onto the boil my recipe
consists of broccoli yeah and broccoli
and broccoli and broccoli and broccoli
boiling rapidly I can't believe it's so
simple because once we've cooked the
broccoli in that water we're then going
to strain it yeah and add the water back
to the broccoli on
Dave's simple broccoli soup contains 16
ingredients including pricey cream and
butter mine is just three broccoli salt
and water it costs Pence and it took a
lot less time to make
I love the color what's the first thing
that comes into your mind God that is so
tasty of broccoli
saw your toast and it gives me that
sense of Christ that's Moorish I want
more because it tastes of broccoli
understand the next one I'm gonna taste
that one
Dave likes it but what about his misses
which one would you pay for
I don't like either you don't like
either yeah [__] him now that's too
plain and nice team from now on you're
staying out the kitchen yeah nothing to
do with your food nothing to do with any
Tangerine nectarine [__] mango yeah
fantastic
Dave you're now in control of your
kitchen thank you
okay [__] off
[__] off thank you
how not to run a restaurant
rule number five don't give your
establishment a name that makes it sound
like a strip joint
Subway 41 first floor restaurant license
Cafe Restaurant [__] hell no I think
your name something positive something
that Rings what's your surname
the Pringles
brindley's Bistro Cafe
what's your surname Jackson Jackson
sounds good and it's
to marry me babe aren't you so I'm a
Jackson team yeah it was more pressure
now everything costs me money are you
proposing isn't it your job to propose
it's the love of my life so there you go
we'll take a day off easy take a day off
and I'll marry you so long as it's on
the cards then
you're sure now sorry yeah and then you
settle on that 100 100 100
.
3 and nectarine fog that's been
surrounding Dave appears finally to be
lifting are you in touch with Blackpool
what's all the chefs using at the moment
what's the what's the latest big thing
what's caught locally what's from the
fish market what's down the veg Market
no I don't have to put hand on heart and
say no no because I'd rely on these
suppliers yeah we lost Direction it's
gone badly wrong um you've got to keep
your ear close to the ground so what do
you want from Blackpool
I want people to come and have good
honest
food
that's it a nutshell
that's what I want and how far are you
away from that now miles
probably further than we are from the
restaurant now
it takes a brave man to acknowledge his
businesses on the brink of collapse but
I've not given up hope on Dave yes
we've hit rock bottom yeah we've hit
rock bottom now we're going up and if
you can't stand the heat [__] off out
the kitchen buff out the kitchen hold on
tight
[__] you know
[Music]
yes it's my fourth day in Blackpool and
it's ration of the Year clubway 41 is no
longer yeah look look all coming down
fantastic from today this place will be
known simply as Jackson's
can you get that [__] banner down as
well please yeah we'll give that back to
the tourist board but even with a
facelift we're still breaking a cardinal
rule in how not to run a restaurant
[Music]
rule number six first floor
establishments are notoriously difficult
to film so to give Dave and Dawn's new
Venture a fighting chance I've come up
with a radical idea I think you're
missing a real serious trick here this
Cafe functions brilliantly during the
day and I think we should look
at moving the restaurant and operating
the restaurant from here in the evening
but I stood outside last night and I
looked and thought God that Frontage
Russians would die for that kind of
Frontage out there no it's not yeah the
kitchen's on show there's an atmosphere
going on there's a bit of banter you've
got all the bus stops all the locals
going home yeah when someone walks past
them they see this place full what are
they gonna do they want to come in and
eat it is a nice room to work and plus
No Buses no foam I can see David it's
one-on-one they can see him and it's
more of a partnership for the two of us
then the customers are coming in seen us
both in our environment not Dave stuck
in the kitchen and popping down when he
can so I can't Portugal milk coffee's
head down here but we have got a Cellar
aren't we
tomorrow night we've invited 50
influential people to launch the new
name
and to match its fresh clean exterior
we've come up with a fresh clean simple
menu have you made a castle before no no
you know medical before no no
[__] me 47 years ago 30 years ago
probably occasional College it's time to
nail rule number seven don't attempt to
cook elaborate food before you've
mastered the very Basics we'll start off
with just roasting off the vegetables
right and then we'll Brown the meat put
it all into pot and let it cook nice and
slow about an hour and a half I've got
just 36 hours to teach Jackson's inept
head chef how to cook Nigel you're doing
potatoes yes once they're finished we're
gonna make a fish stop yeah that's gonna
be our base for fish soup
lamp beautifully colored off let's see
how dark is that there is all about
Flavor there that whole thing there is
just pure flavor using inexpensive
produce fresh from the local markets
ninety percent of this new food can be
prepared in advance so she's like lamb
casserole pork terrine and fish soup are
designed to take the heat off during
service
that's it nicely mixed the aim is to get
Dave and Nigel sending out delicious
tasty food to a dining room full of
customers without Dave having a nervous
breakdown in the process you're free
you're free to control it and do it
properly without having to do 20 things
at once yeah I understand next up we're
prepping some locally caught fish for a
deliciously simple soup right go and
just give me a handy a minute please
yeah see the knife yeah then watch it
all the way down to the tail yep
right eyes out yep and just cut it up
into quarters any specific way or just
well it's only for a fish stock Dave so
wherever where you feel fit okay this is
like pulling teeth any that hasn't
actually been killed the castle before
yeah or Philadelphia Fish shouldn't be
rolling a [__] restaurant
so let's get cracking on with the fish
soup cook off your muscles
and we'll save the juicer and we cook
mussels before no
you're pulling my plonker now aren't you
you've never cooked a muscle all right
we can shower you can [__] it out I
don't mind what do you mean not gonna
help
yeah okay fine you're right sorry what
have we do for the last two hours fine
so what we want in here I'm just amazed
you've never cooked a mustard don't take
the piss at me for it though oh who's
taking the person I don't think you can
actually cook if you eat a [__]
chocolate if you can't cook a [__]
mustard yeah
hey come on yeah finish it then finish
well
I'm about to say cook a muscle no I
haven't cooked one right okay right so
I'll show you how to cook a muscle oh at
last thank you yes please right are you
gonna tone your voice down or you're
gonna shout like some dick I'll shout
like some dick and then I'll calm down
right now why don't you [__] off to the
Bookshop read how to cook a muscle and
come back and see me yeah and I'll run
your [__] restaurant thank you clonka
[__]
what's up Jesus Christ well at least he
wrote the ice now anyway we know where
we stand yeah
yeah five minutes after he put his toys
back in his pram Dave returned ready and
willing to learn how to cook mussels
well we're doing is steaming them now
not quite we've done more on the last
[__] hour than we have in three days
yeah yeah I know more about you and you
know more about [__] me yes Patricia
thank you Gordon Gordon
rule number eight don't assume you can
run a restaurant just because you've
worked in one
sometimes you know when I listen to you
talk about food and the way you are in a
kitchen I'm concerned that you fall in
love
with becoming a great chef but forgot to
go through the Journey to get there what
do you mean by a great chef I mean to
reach no no [__] all to do with me
you're not working for someone else now
you're working for yourself and you know
this is on his ass the business can't
get any worse I just don't want you to
get in a situation where you think that
you're going to be blackpool's best chef
because for as long as you've got a hole
on your ass that's never going to happen
all right
Dave and Dawn will be better off with a
new chef but they simply can't afford
one right now there he is Mookie the
clown has agreed to try and work some
Miracles with what we've got
now that man's got amazing coordination
skills
that's good that's it slow that's
brilliant that's brilliant leading a
successful kitchen takes tremendous
concentration so what we're doing really
is creating that momentum only you've
got to constantly be thinking ahead to
keep on top of the game
just like being in the kitchen yeah and
creating that momentum with great
coordination skills a table three table
four together putting two tables
together yeah sending three tables
together here we go now we have to take
them off
maybe a crash course in control in his
kitchen but at last something seems to
be sinking in
Come On Dave you can do this see
[Music]
thank you very much take it back
with the launch of Jackson's Restaurant
just 12 hours away it's new downstairs
venue is being treated to a facelift
it's goodbye to the old clinical Cafe
and hello to a warm and inviting
restaurant
what a difference huh brilliant it looks
absolutely amazing it really does looks
absolutely smashing there very nice
there's loads to do food for the new
simplified menu needs to be prepared
practiced waste nothing
for the bottom same amount for the top
two and a half minutes each side I never
thought of having a birthday never in a
million years and just to make sure
we're instigating idiot proof measures
so take the air out
okay one nice portion so water's boiling
rapidly it goes in
you cut the top off and it's away it
couldn't be easier but a Russian's first
night is everything and the team can't
afford to put a foot wrong
David is your restaurant yeah big night
is there anything you think that you
can't do no
no anything you want to change nope lamb
Castle bring it vegetable middle of the
play meet in the middle dumplings on the
side pushing pushing in here push push
push push question the question running
through your mind then it becomes fluid
fluid happy [__] customers full
dining room and everything moves okay
okay the newly incarnated Jacksons has
got to be a slick operation
Jacksons that looks nice two quarters of
14 pounds two courses 18 pounds down
that doesn't sound expensive two courses
14 pound three courses 18. shoot that
looks nice
hey welcome to Jackson's nice new
Immaculate hats proper hats just do me a
favor you look the part cook the part
good luck everyone thank you very much
stay cool stay calm yes and communicate
oh my first customers hey guys
yes you are good evening it's nice to
meet you welcome to Jackson all right
ladies from the tourist board don't
mention the banner
I feel like I'm just about to light the
fuse and let it explode
which gamble putting Dave and his nerves
on show but maybe an audience is exactly
what he needs to focus
[Music]
because what's happening nice nice Buzzy
restaurant we'll keep it that way yes
here we go one check on please okay one
mackerel salad one soup one lamb one
steak
Dave's off to a good start
he's got a confidence about him I
haven't seen before
and he appears to be in control
thank you sir this please
table two two top one macro
okay I've got a table twos macro and
pateau and that won't break okay I'm
going to go with over 10 Mains and table
seven starters that's main course now
first main course now it's over 10.
let's go service please made your waves
over 10. the plates are spinning but
will Dave be able to keep them up come
on guys okay nicely seasoned Nigel's
been as clear and concise with his
Stakes as he is with his bacon and eggs
medium one steak medium well medium well
darling medium
okay table two gone Dave thank you
okay service please table one one Pate
one tarte
thank you check please even in his
Heyday this place has never been so busy
thank you service please table five
and there's nothing more alluring to
potential customers than an attractive
buzzing restaurant
there's nothing difficult here soup to
reheat everything's cool even the
potatoes are cooked salad Grill the
Mackle put it onto a plate
anything else because it's so I was told
what have you just sent Nigel five okay
yeah yeah don't forget your lemon but 50
minutes in and the kitchen's having
trouble keeping pace
okay okay
what I'm doing nowaday right what goes
without these starters
those plates are beginning to wobble
David don't burn any of that mackerel we
need everything as an order now you know
sorry don't burn that Mackle I won't be
here next week so Dave and Nigel have
got to prove to each other they can do
this on their own
now please
come out together yeah can we serve them
all champagne for those people that
haven't got starters or some wine or
something yeah just keep them happy
because there's actually Six Tables
waiting for the starters I need seven
and six next but I need the Stars on
eight
Michael needs some pans mate please
and you've got to stay well done
you're here yeah I got one statement I
did say that Dave's plates are no longer
wobbling they're crashing down around
him
I haven't got mistake
an hour after they ordered customers are
being told their choice of main course
is no longer available and we need these
customers back I've had the startership
so already we've gone back to the table
so we've got no steak so how long for
those starters though 11 and 12.
okay it's fine watch those steaks that's
all we've got left you know that the two
medium well please okay yeah okay
despite all the delays Dawn's waiting
team have managed to keep the customers
happy they gave us an extra glass of
champagne that was lovely that's made
our night
a little bit tipsy now but we're all
right level nine please the food has
looked a hell of a lot better
the mackerel started it was beautiful I
really enjoyed that we've had a
wonderful evening and the food went well
if it's all around my mouth I'm sorry
even more miraculously Davis got through
it
without having a nervous breakdown
[Music]
it's not perfect by a long chalk
but they've come a hell of a long way in
a week
the following morning Dave and Dawn have
had a booking for 10 based on a
recommendation from last night you can't
get better feedback than that
morning good morning Gordon how are you
up
thank you there's a present
nice how are you feeling
yeah very well very positive about last
night actually it's just sort of what
you know give us another two three
services and uh we have it Top Notch
it's not until you work something
that you find it's pitfalls so and now
we worked it and we saw the pitfalls so
now we know which areas to look in
Dawn Sparkle and energy are perfect for
front of house I just need to be sure
she'll steer well clear of that menu
last night I stood outside and just
looked and saw the rest in full you're
busy and buzzing and feeding off the
customers and bouncing offers the base
now the start for something that we
think is going to really take off yeah
my concerns with David is I don't want
him getting Beyond his station again I
don't want you filling his head with
Bree believe me it's never going to
happen again I've listened to it no
menus this is my [__]
last night worked and you so know it
[__] works like that nothing more I
want you to keep hold of that it was
nice it buzzing again it was simple it's
all about organization yeah but don't
get too ambitious and certainly don't
turn it into something pretentious
because that
is going to close this place
I know money's time and finances are
difficult in time I want you to look for
a new Chef it's crucial yeah I agree
with that one more thing
keep the [__] nectarines in the fruit
salad yeah keep the nectarines in the
fruit salad yes not with [__]
battered out pork there you go thank you
look after that lady I will do bye guys
thanks thank you drive carefully please
thank you
damn I forgot to mention rule nine
you're only as good as your last service
[Music]
eight months ago I came to Blackpool on
a mission to breed some life back into
his failing ration of the Year table two
two moves one bread pudding haven't got
it but a quick resuscitation for Club
841 was out of the question that's
probably the worst Source ever tasted in
my entire life they were breaking every
rule in the book I don't think you can
actually cook if you're the [__] joke
get rid of the [__] name
put out for a week we'd moved Heaven and
Earth to make the new Jacksons a going
concern
and by the skin of our teeth we we just
about pulled it off we gave us an extra
glass of champagne that was lovely
that's made our night
I left Dawn and Dave at the end of
Blackpool season with a Chance of
surviving a long Bleak winter
Summer's here and they're still open
how are you yeah very well thank
yourself
on the surface the place is looking
great
[Music]
please
but it's soon clear that things are far
from Rosy and where's uh night well now
it was gone because
no it's gone because I think it's
probably better like that you're missing
a chef things must be bad I was hoping
day was going to recruit reinforcements
in the kitchen not get rid of them so
getting through the winter was the most
important thing which you managed to do
I remember but we didn't I didn't think
it would be that hard all the way
through January February we carried on
nothing and then we ended up with this
bus station we're right outside
we can't have the doors open in the
summer because the the fumes the diesel
fumes are disgusting this is a terrible
twist of fate they've just about
survived the winter and now a bus
exchange has landed on their doorstep
apart from physically drag these people
into the building I really don't know
what more we can do I mean we've worked
our asses off all year with debts at an
all-time high Dave and Dawn shut down
the evening restaurant just two months
after Jackson's relaunch it just seems a
a missed opportunity if you've been that
idea so early when you you worked at it
for
six seven weeks if I hadn't done it and
cut my costs we wouldn't be here now
literally in a desperate effort to save
money in the cafe they've shut
themselves in the foot by ousting
home-cooked food they're back to box
standard Frozen Blackpool fare so it's
just Cafe food you're just holding this
breakfast yeah what about the specials
especially we've been up there I mean we
just have the board up there now
if summer tray doesn't pick up soon Dave
and Dawn will lose everything you
thought about you have to speculate to
accumulate yeah of course they piss you
off but turn it round to your advantage
so I've come up with a unique marketing
strategy using the god awful buses to
bring fresh food and customers back to
Jackson's Cafe the
as an incentive through the summer 2005
and you know look delicious home-cooked
evening specials after 6 p.m yeah very
good idea are you happy I'm happy with
that yeah
so for our summertime special it's fresh
fish and chip for mum and dad and free
homemade chicken nuggets and mini
burgers for the kids so they're not
coming to us
[__] it we're going to go to them we're
doing some homemade specials this
evening and if you order a special
little girl will leave for free
everything's homemade so we'll see you
in about what half an hour
Jackson's on Market Street yes thank you
on the adult special we've got Fleetwood
fresh caught fish beer batter you like
burgers don't you big boy yeah
At Last I smile Dawn's a natural
saleswoman so why isn't she out here
every evening everything's homemade on
the premises fresh today fantastic
produce and we start at six o'clock this
evening what's your favorite food what
do you like
Curry's off the menu
thank you the past eight months have
clearly been very hard but to survive
you can't let it get you down
you know the place is better than the
cafe I think that's mine
yeah that's my my gripe there must be a
500 cafes that serve full of this
breakfast in Blackpool if he's got any
chances of Ivy you know you've got to be
better than that you [__] on the ass
like that and the business is so [__]
weird we've got no choice have we huh
come on don't be upset come here come on
don't be silly huh
very good
strong
to get back and cook some good shots
yeah would you fancy a swim no it's a
sniff well you always you already wears
huh standing in a [__] swimming pool
tonight's a chance to lift the bar and
convince the punters that Jackson's
home-cooked fresh food is A Cut Above
the Rest are you set up for uh for
dinner I'm just about yeah I've just got
these but Dave and Dawn have got to
stick to their guns I was a little bit
miffed this morning when I heard that it
only went for six weeks that's not long
enough to try it and I think what you're
doing is listening to the first or
second customer and then that's setting
your thoughts for the next three four
months I really had to look at the cost
big style yeah you know at the end of
the January Now The Season's here we
have the chance to evolve it yeah in
these over the next like 12 to 14 weeks
we've got to make a noise Dave this is
uh you know a cafe it's a smart place
but you've got to get that message
across and you've got to continue
putting that message out there
our PR exercise has paid off
the customers are flocking in
fine thank you
Dave's at home cooking this food and
it's flying out okay we need four
goujons out please
and the home cooking seems to be hitting
the spot
[Music]
nice crispy batter very tasty
on the Cod
that's delicious you can do it yeah this
is simple I might actually answer for
the [__] recipe
Charles Burger Charles burger no chips
okay well I'm convinced how about the
kids
[Music]
out of the ten how many would you mark
it
um so that means it was a really good
burger the meal Deal's been a real
success and the fresh food has proved
its worth the food was 100 times better
Customs were happy weren't they yeah
kids are in there you had to go off the
street and drag them in but you know
that's what's going to take to get this
place back great on his food that will
fill a restaurant yeah yeah yeah it's
not that difficult yeah is it no no
this is a rule book because when I first
came to Jackson's or clubway at the time
yeah it was everything a Russian
shouldn't be
read this there's one special rule rule
number 10 don't think your life savings
into opening a restaurant if you're in
any doubt of success if I ask you to
turn the clock back for two years
because you're bought Subway 41 knowing
what I know now yeah no
but hindsight it's always an exact
science but with what we've learned we
will carry that and it will work
look what you've been through yeah don't
bin it read another rule before I go my
lucky number number seven don't attempt
to cook elaborate for you before you've
mastered the basics
Sound Advice lovely bedtime reading
tonight bedtime really big time hey
[Music]
yes yeah
Dave and Dawn have been through the mill
but if they can stay focused for the
rest of the season they might just be
here next year
it's actually a shot you don't get a
shot then
this is where David needs to sit inside
so we can wake him up and get his numb
[__] head out of his brain nectarines
and get back to some good honest food
the [__]
[Music]
this week I'm in Derby for my biggest
challenge yet I got awful Italian
restaurant that's stuck in a Time Warner
it sounds like prices that were in
existence [__] 10-15 years ago a
truly miserable kitchen I've been saying
it for three days we haven't got a pot
washer nobody's done a [__] thing
about it
with appalling food the chickens raw and
I don't want to catch salmonella in
[__] Derby unless I can help her new
owner Daniela has just spent half a
million quid on a sinking ship oh we
might do a close down now and I can save
my money
[Music]
when the gondola opened in 1968 its
Italian owners brought the glamor of
Venice to Dowdy Derby
and it instantly became the place to be
seen you couldn't get into this place
unless you booked two or three weeks in
advance the place was packed had
wonderful atmosphere and it had a
reputation then of being the best
restaurant in Derby Daniela celebrated
her 21st birthday at lagondla she even
got married in the restaurant she loves
it so much six months ago she bought the
company but just what had she bought
[Music]
my Bayer in Derby [__] hell the size
of it
a 125-seater restaurant with a 21
bedroom hotel attached a big undertaking
especially for state of the outside is
anything to go by
[__] me even the gondola looks [__]
hello
good evening Mr Anthony Gordon good good
and Daniela Daniel how are you
thank you for seeing you thank you for
coming together so God it's a
it's uh it's like going back in time it
is it's a bit of a Time Warner how old
is it
um nearly 40 years old really even the
floorboards are I know creaking as well
fantastic anyone under there uh no
there's a wine cellar oh I love the old
wine so yeah fantastic
it's 49 8 o'clock and I can hear a few
clinking plates in there but um the
place sounds empty how many books for
dinner
four
four yes a table of four and that's all
and that is our problem we have this
beautiful restaurant and it's empty most
of the time
one question I've got to ask why the
hell did you buy it if you've never run
a restaurant or a hotel before well when
my mother died and I went through a
divorce it was the one thing one night
that kept me going I also thought that's
what I'll do I'll buy lagondra and all
night long I just dreamed of this place
oh some customers coming now sorry
okay good night good night to enjoy
dinner yes sir excellent
damn I like to lift the teeth on the
table
from its 70s chandeliers to his plastic
flowers the restaurant is well and truly
past him
he's like stepping back in time it is
and I wondered whether should we really
decorate it or wait till the fashion
turns and come back to it I mean
but it'll be too late if the business
goes down the pan first
everywhere you look
um it's like a flashback to the 70s even
the food sounds you know that dating
smoked salmon honeydew melon with Port
warm brie with their tomato tart
the menu is massive nearly 100 dishes
and very few of them actually Italian
um I'd like to start with the um let's
pick The Bolognese please
it's at him yes it says fresh spaghetti
it did thank you
I've ordered the simplest start on the
menu but it seems to be taking a very
long time
get him on some [__] proper spaghetti
now he's going to give the [__]
ancient [__] that was in there
[Music]
you do it
don't worry the problem in the kitchen
that's that's been difficult
nice thank you
I apologize about the weight
that's that was cooked to order which if
you only got four customers in the
evening [__] right it's gonna be
cooked to water
big portions for starter
I'm mounting a spag bowl and a salmon
main course to come
all for six pounds 50 no wonder they're
losing money
right got us see if you can go to the
lobster soup without them seeing you
after seeing something very dodgy the
silver vegetables
and even in 1999 Silver Service or
vegetables like that was 25 years too
late thank you the salmon is also
massive and like the restaurant a
bewildering trip through time as the
years have progressed you're just adding
more onto it oh [__] it it's
1975 let's stick a muscle in there
it's 1980 let's stick some launch two on
there do you know what this 1985
Ratatouille is in sticks of Ratatouille
on there and it's 1990. welcome back the
roast spurt quantity not quality a
classic 1970s mistake and surprise
surprise how are you head chef Steve's
drawn started here in 1975. I've never
seen such massive portions in my entire
life right it doesn't need the prawns
doesn't need the muscles it's described
on the menu as that so yeah I've got to
follow through with what's on the menu
but when you've been here for that
length of time you could change that and
just do a simple poached salmon dish
without all that do I could do yeah
there's two ways in this industry you
move with the times
well the times moves you and
unfortunately you've been caught in a
Time warm
[Music]
in my experience when a Russian's been
stuck in a rut for so long Rock starts
setting in start getting really lazy
they start cutting corners and they
really need to discover exactly what's
going on here
today there's a 70th birthday party in
the restaurant
functions of the Lifeboat of Lagonda but
there's not even enough of those to stop
it dying on his ass
at the moment for this year I've got
nine weddings booked but really we
should be aiming for about 30 weddings a
year and then that would be very nice
25 covers is a chance for me to see how
the kitchen copes when they have more
than four people through the door
I've done 404
mm-hmm
10 minutes in the kitchen's already in
trouble they've run out of fresh tuna
steaks you know you're gonna have to do
plan B
they do it's called Plan B do you know
about Plan B Plan B plan me
no I don't what's Plan B when he's at
home
oh tins that's what it means right
tin tuna bang down on limp letters my
grandma would have been ashamed to have
served that it doesn't fail like a
kitchen no energy no excitement no
passion really and sort of cares and
love for food get in the bowl and [__]
up out here excuse me sweetheart now
there's a problem with the mains oh
sorry it's no sauce oh no sauce
what is the airplane I know
about that
just straight on the phone to Stella the
business manager yeah it doesn't say
playing on the menu does it we never
serve a plane
[Applause]
Chef's wrong again
never the office
not really
sort out on Monday
[Music]
Stella cocked up the order for the
lobster sauce but instead of rolling his
sleeves up and getting on with it Steve
picks a fight are you going upstairs
Stella I just asked Danielle at the
combustion pots at all
I've been seeing it for three days we
haven't got a pot washer nobody's done a
[__] thing about it
yeah
well they're all bickering the waiters
are still serving the main course
it's a shambles lagondle wants to be a
high-class restaurant and yet they're
slopping out reheated catering rubbish
Belgium apple pie
what's Belgium about it
did you buy them in yeah yeah I can
right yeah yeah but from a chef to
Chef's Point of View you know damn well
an apple pie yeah
yeah exactly so you're telling me now
that you're happier to buy them in
rather than make them at this moment no
I'm happier to make myself but I don't
have the stuff for the skills all the
time to do it okay how long does it take
to make an apple pie
half an hour 40 minutes
microwaving yeah yeah what this guy
needs is a rocket up his ass
this is a [__] Donald for you isn't
it
yep it's not exactly ball break in here
is it it has been in the past and it
kind of yeah we're going back today it's
almost like we're paying for your
memories again today is quiet right
bring it back I'll still handle it okay
now okay
Daniela sunk half a million quid of a
divorce settlement into lagondla but
last year alone it lost 75 grand
he doesn't open her eyes to what's
happening in her kitchen she'll be left
with nothing but memories and debts
let's be brutally honest you fell in
love with the place and you grew up in
it and you had your 21st birthday party
had your wedding here and you have
bought
a [__] time bomb I've never seen a
kitchen like that that just
has so little atmosphere no banter no
communication no vibrant let's get ready
for a great lunch it was
um turkey going in cooked the day before
reheated
um I'm horrified that we had that if
you're telling me a Discerning customer
cannot tell the difference but I think
we've really got to pick up on and wake
up on is the fact that your chef
can lose his self-esteem by serving that
[__] they've carved a very comfortable
Niche out for themselves and they've
made a really comfortable bed to lion
and unfortunately you're paying the
price for that
[Music]
I'm pretty pissed off you know that I'm
not happy because what I saw yesterday
across the board I thought was a [__]
disgrace
[Music]
La Gondola and Derby at first I thought
this restaurant's problem was that it
was stuck in a Time Warp but it goes far
deeper than that
it's 10 o'clock and head chef Steve and
he's number two Gareth are only just
rolling up for work
you wouldn't get away with that in my
kitchen especially as last year the
Russian lost 75 grand these guys just
don't seem to be interested in turning
the place around
how much is the restaurant taken this
week barely
500 quid
yeah
the salaries alone in the kitchen are a
thousand pounds if the restaurant didn't
have these functions that are drip
feeding into this establishment yeah
you wouldn't have a job I personally
want to put a [__] rocket up
everyone's ass in here today to really
make them understand what you should be
doing
and not bickering and festering on
[__] memories from 20 years ago that
means [__] all
[Music]
it's Sunday lunchtime and there are
three diners at the gondola when there
isn't a function on well nothing much
happens in this kitchen
right we are away we're away chefs away
as well he's been away for 30 [__]
years
Mains away Chef please
not quite ready not quite ready this
kitchen is
there how many eaters you work a week
straight
three to four depends on the business
really yeah just to play by yeah it
berries
yeah what a bizarre setup
[Music]
36 years yeah wow amazing so you are the
asset yes
so um if the food was to change you
wouldn't come back
no what you've got you've got minestrone
soup minestrone soup but Lagonda are
going to have to risk losing their three
regular diners because this is a
terrible environment for an aspiring
young Chef
number two garage is only 19. but he's
already given up it was good wasn't it
there must be Soldier strong when the
business is so quiet though
motivation wise no
it's boring yeah very boring when it's
quiet
[Music]
watching until it's 10 o'clock so you
can go because we can't go early in case
someone does come no so it's just you
just clock watching all the time yeah
I've only seen one person in this
kitchen with any real drive or ambition
and that 17 year old Apprentice Danny
Holden you're right Danny Boy he's doing
a [__] good job yeah my pleasure
that's where it all started you know
that I've been in the lonely place in
amongst all those bubbles
ah but trust me if you get your [__] to
get in there it goes from bubbles on top
of the sink to Bubbles in glass and
champagne
champagne I'm not old enough
[__] it'll sneak in the fridge okay yeah
Young Chefs need encouragement but
discipline is high on Steve's list of
priorities
I don't stand any nonsense you don't
understand any nonsense and if these
don't make it they go I've told them all
out I don't I'm not standing for nothing
this one might not last a week
are you ready oh yesterday yesterday it
was very close I don't hang around with
one warning and two warnings but no out
the [__] back door mate
Gareth you know good you walk
[Music]
Steve thinks he can talk the talk but
can he really walk the walk this time I
checked out he's still covered
in evidence
so
I mean it looks like fish food doesn't
it
and it smells [__] disgusting
there you go
it's half a container plastic minestrone
soup
foreign
Ty Italian restaurant and yet she's
completely unaware what's happening in
her own kitchen
um
the mini Stoney soup is quite uh
it is it's very good it's excellent
almost as good as my mother's yeah um
great why'd you buy it in Steve I don't
buy it then I make it myself
so the containers the bought in
minestrone soup and the invoices here
what we do we wouldn't mix that 50 50.
we'll sort of give half and half really
it seems to be yeah I'm not clear what
do you mean two bowls one of them no
would make half up with perhaps packet
and then put fresh in to it as well it's
these penny pinching by bulking up the
fresh soup with powdered but the prices
are so out of date on the menu they're
hemorrhaging money on a daily basis the
cost of the Lamb nothing more just the
lamb cutlets yeah that whole dish okay
should be on the menu at 16 pound fifty
right you're selling it
at 10 pound 90. but the scary thing is
Steve that you don't know that every
time we sell that lamb yeah we're losing
five quid yeah yeah and if we're at the
table of four in today yeah and they
walked in that door I swear to God it'd
be a lot easier to [__] stop them at
the door and say there's your five pound
and [__] off closed down now and I can
save my money you know I'm glad about
people who've been here for years and
they're telling me they can make money
out of that menu but you were here in
place in position as the manager when
this was put together
it's my money Steve not yours that's
that's carry on let's put a structure in
place just a minute let's put a
structure
all I needed to do was cover costs all
right and I did more than cover costs on
that
don't go off saying this that and the
other you could be out of a job in a
month's time
no one is taking responsibility for
lagondola's problems everyone just
blames each other
and I get really nervous because I think
you're the kind of cook that's just
going to [__] off at you know that I
think you're going to get upset one day
after listening to where you spoke to
the owner if that was me I would have
sacked you and My worry is you're so
determined to [__] work in this
industry you need to get excited you
need to start cooking properly
[Music]
got to get these guys out of this
god-awful kitchen
I'll try and lift them around so I'm
taking them to see one of Derby's most
successful businesses yeah Gareth you
drive you know we're going to look at
some history
[Music]
all right let's go and look at something
beautiful something that's moved with
time Rolls Royce
1933. look at it
beautiful now the next one is something
quite interesting because this was made
in 1979. look at it a bit of history
that Rolls-Royce didn't sit still
yeah and get moved by The Times They
decided to move ahead of the times the
Phantom what's it like in there Danny
it's nice and comfy business and Steve I
don't know what to say yeah they've
moved on they haven't just stood there
and sort of expected Rolls-Royce to sell
and unfortunately big boy when I first
saw your food I felt like I was stepping
in a time capsule yeah I'll get your
point it did it's marvelous it's
marvelous absolutely I know a chef has
got one of these you know that and
you're thinking Gareth what should do
rob a bank or work hard
bollocks should we knit round and see
your mum Danny
the engine that powers any successful
restaurant is its kitchen and light
Rolls Royce La Gondola is going to have
to create its own modern Classics I'm
starting with that lunch menu
what's the secret behind any good
Italian restaurant
Pastor exactly when was last time you
made fresh pasta Never Enough there we
go you're making it I'm just going to
tell you how to make it so make it well
in the center that's it I'm keeping it
simple so the chefs have got time to get
up to speed out goes the old two course
lunch menu for six pounds fifty in comes
a fresh pasta May with a salad and a
glass of wine for eight pounds 95.
see the color it's starting to change
now because the saffron's working on
there fresh pasta is the Hallmark of an
authentic Italian restaurant its
Simplicity also makes it a money spinner
far cheaper than those expensive lamb
specials see the color of it all of it
ricotta in and I want you to taste it as
you're doing it there you go now okay
watch yeah like a parcel exactly look
fold it over
nip all the air out little finger
over left to right right to left use
your thumb and push
totally who'd like a go
yeah of course you can have a go here we
go we've only been making a pasta for 10
minutes and already the young chefs look
like they're enjoying themselves I
finally injected some passion into this
kitchen
[Music]
you've just done
10 minutes ago there's your first one
yeah no but that's your first you've
never made pasta and now you've made
your first ever tortellini that's very
good
I've asked Danny The Apprentice to come
up with a couple of salads for the new
menu
what I've done is I've put like tomato
in that in The Mixing Bowl good and well
with the shots and you put like there's
that and like that sort of really good
stuff over it okay I'm a little taste
eat with me and this one is a is rocket
and Parmesan good man cheese that's
lovely
but the Gondola's problems aren't just
in the kitchen to help me relaunch this
sinking ship I've called in the boss of
the company that does all my restaurants
PR
awns
well it certainly makes the first
impression up the creaky stairs
wow done
amazing Chandelier and you look at the
dance floor just how many heels I've
been dancing on this you can kind of see
El Deco doing a special on you know
Interiors Frozen in time yeah and do you
think there's a sellable asset here do
you think you could sell those
restaurants my first feelings when I
come in and I don't mean to be negative
are
start all over again this place badly
needs a refurbishment you can refurb it
you can call it a new name and start
over and really relaunch it however with
the money fine no but it does have is a
tremendous amount of authenticity and
kind of kitsy appeal yeah and I love the
sort of you know the Doric columns and
the dance floor and I suppose you've got
to work with what you've got Daniela and
her business manager Stella need Joe's
help because so far their marketing
efforts have hardly set Darby a light I
can't even find it on here it's supposed
to be under restaurants under
Continental
oh there we go Jesus Christ so we go
past all these um relaxing massage and
all these [__] houses and you come down
here
and the lagondola try our new menus
booking's now been taken I mean you know
you've missed it
what you've got to do is identify what
your real strengths are here and that's
the family-run business that's the the
Great Space you've got with the dance
floor and make them into selling points
you've got to have a Punchy message with
which you can appeal to your potential
customers now the Russian reputation has
disappeared
conversation hasn't disappeared the
problem is that people have forgotten
about La Gondola it hasn't got a bad
reputation definitely not so it's a good
reputation
you're not being honest with yourself it
has a [__] reputation it hasn't I'm
telling you it has so you've been to
Derby and you've had a word with all of
the
all of them all of the customers there
are no customers the place is empty so
you're telling me that the people who
put adverts in the paper Thanking us for
a superb wedding Etc you're missing my
point if you just listen to what I'm
trying to tell you it may make sense in
a minute
the add-ons from having a successful
restaurant is phenomenal we haven't got
that reputation any longer the business
is on his ass and the functions over the
last 10 years have depleted accepted
there is no reputation at the gondola
and if you're going to stand there and
tell me it's a good place when a chef
Buys in minestrone soup
no chance
we need to spread the word around Darby
that the gondola is changing so I've
told Stella to get on the phone and
Round Up members of the city business
Community for a special lunch a great
way to get the message out and a chance
to see if Steve can lead his team
[Music]
my father used to come here for business
lunches about 25 years ago
but in recent times I have to say it's
not a place that I would have come to
the idea of this lunch today is to get
them in and out in 45 minutes we've
managed Silver Service to speed up the
waiters but can Steve run his kitchen
fast enough
whether we're busy quiet makes no
difference to me I only know one way and
that's the way I do it
yeah you're ready to roll with us yeah
yeah good man this is the exciting part
of the day yeah okay let's go I want you
to clean out the place nice
the new pasta dishes of devise are
hitting the spot
three sends their compliments
that's the first quality again very good
price as well but a little bit slow
coming out just a little bit slow people
having a business lunch once again the
lack of organization has dropped the
kitchen in it Jesus Christ
come on guys there's gonna be a system
in here somewhere Steve if you're if
you're confused yeah let me know and
I'll help you out yeah okay it's gone
all quiet you see you're not leaving
like a head chef do you understand where
all these three guys including Danny's
coming together at the same time so
they've got to take your direction you
know that yeah yeah when you asked for
it we'll do we'll do it for us outside
in the restaurant there are lots of
customers waiting but all the orders
have become mixed up after that so he
sent a table for you three seconds tell
anyone knock you on bruschetta they've
sent them they've just come back and
said they're on coffee you've already
sent their main course
and now a whole table has got the wrong
dishes start again anyways it's gone
Stone Cold
off
[Music]
Digital two starters yeah this is
that was just 35 covers I'm planning to
completely relaunch the restaurant in
only a couple of days time with double
the number of customers I'm starting to
wonder if Steve is really up to it what
has come out of today's lunch
how everyone just works on their own
you're like yeah I've seen no thank you
no understanding no coordination and
bringing these guys together has been a
[__] nightmare
[__] you know I tell you I'm finding it
hard I'm finding it really [__] hard
because it's not about teaching an old
boy New Tricks about getting the old boy
to wake up and stop being a lazy bastard
a simple risotto bruschetta frittata
taglitelli of chicken and they're still
in the ship
laughs
the gondola is up the creek without a
paddle
the kitchen's getting by with bought in
apple pies and the staff don't pull
together I don't know which way
in less than 48 hours a new owner
Daniela is relaunching the restaurant I
woke up at five o'clock this morning uh
I don't have to often swear but I was
[__] scared the trouble is daniela's
head chef has been Treading Water
opening a tin of tuna or a packet of
powdered soup I want to redesign the
menu for the relaunch but what can Steve
actually cook I've asked him to prepare
me a dish using fresh ingredients only
so what's in there butter we've got
butter red onions red onions a little
bit of olive oil yep
fennel fresh funnel just a little bit
of orange zest
flower
and where did this idea come from when I
was a comedy we used to do it when I
worked down in Oxford so 35 years ago
quite a long time yeah yeah Steve is
cooking me a dish of rustic Italian
trout
it's gorgeous and then we can dress it
up yeah
um I was a little bit miffed when you're
frying the um
the trout the fact you had to take the
scales off right so really I've got to
eat this with a pile of [__] in my mouth
why don't you scale the fish sorry this
time it was time yeah it looks like you
forgot
I think that's pretty dismal yeah
for a 51 year old Chef to produce that
part of [__] I'm [__] gobsmacked
the scales are on there it's all in the
roof of my mouth the [__] alcohol's
not burnt off it's
dismal effort I want to find out if the
other chefs can do any better
tuning is very tasty you don't need that
sauce
for me you just stop that dish by
putting that glue on there yeah that
sort of Gloppy stodgy wallpaper paste
that in fact I'd offer that to Daniella
to [__] Plaster the front of the
gondola you know that because that looks
like a pile of [__] there as well what's
that what's that in there inside yeah oh
the chicken's inside yeah is this a
Polish dish
no no the chicken's raw now um
unfortunately I uh I can't afford to
[__] off and die right now and I don't
want to catch salmonella in [__]
Derby so
um put that straight in the bin yeah
yeah I've been poisoned once before and
it's not gonna [__] happen again it's
so scary
we really are in trouble here I've never
sent this message out before in the
Russian I'd tell them [__] move your
ass get on with it otherwise you're out
but I'm gonna tell you guys to stop and
give up don't fight it if you don't want
to change and when that change comes in
be prepared to work [__] hard
we've got to get rid of all this crap
we can't carry 80 89 dishes
what's it like when this man's off in
the night and you've got 25 books it
must be mad no
when you cook like that do you actually
think that you're fit enough to call
yourself a chef if you're defrosting
things and deep fine mushrooms and is it
important for you to cook or are you
really seriously interested in staying
the way you are cool you are you
definitely want to cook
yeah away I got that complicated
the only option is to go right back to
basics I've devised a new dinner menu
That's so simple hopefully it's
foolproof a light knocking with salmon
and tarragon and a simple tomato a
mozzarella risotto it's just a little
bit too thicker even this kitchen surely
can't cook these dishes up
[Music]
fresh fragrant mix stand up please Steve
thank you yeah it's really hard for you
to understand at 19 how modern we're
trying to put the approach yeah
nothing's coming out of the [__]
packet nothing's coming out underneath
cook [__] three days ago it's just
clean fresh and just think back
to that Phantom that roller
is it worth getting out of bed in the
morning yeah [__] right it is
really easy okay yeah so it doesn't all
stick
[Music]
[Applause]
then he's never been given his own
section so I'm going to see how he does
with the vegetables he's gonna look out
for me almost as if you're sort of in
love with him look beautiful swarming it
it's very warm isn't it ah Welcome to
the Real World of the kitchen big boy
you're sweating
huh that looks cool first time is it the
first time you sweat it in the kitchen
yeah good man
yep so now we've done the peppers yep
the aubergine the butternut squash yes
and now all of a sudden Big Boy over the
last couple of hours yes you've been
running the vegetable section
move your ass
we now have a new contemporary menu for
the relaunch time to Chuck out the chins
Stella
let me ask you something you're sat just
come and touch us a minute and close
your eyes and just touch it
yeah
[__] disgusting dirty
grubby smelly plastic flowers yeah the
Clutter on the tables Martin because
those will come out the [__] pound
shop you like an old [__] woman that
just won't throw anything away get rid
of it it's going tonight good it's like
going to an airport lounge and looking
at one of the Chapels of rest
it's the kind of thing you'd see in
there when you sort of sit down and
grieve I mean I'm sorry but they're
[__] awful catch get hold of them all
and love them in the skip
yeah
good man already I feel like [__] out
I got rid of my Granny's pants they're
off they're no longer appear I'm
starting to think about wearing a nice
sexy pair of knickers because I've just
seen the white tablecloths go down
that's how I feel in here it looks clean
and fresh would you wear knickers up to
there Stella oh don't start God stick to
the restaurant
would you wear a pair of my knickers up
to here no so get rid of the flowers
but I have discovered one thing from the
past worth hanging on to
so this is from the whole classic menu
we used to wear yeah all done on the
table all done at the table and so now
you stopped it because I mean at one
time certainly not used to be just one
person just do the cooking all night
so you're taking that to what lightly
brown just nice and golden brown
I've asked Martin for a demo because I
think the flambez are due for comeback
Jesus Christ
did you miss this oh yeah you're so
[__] good at it yes I hope so I tried
doing my best anyway
but this should be the um Hallmark of
the restaurant this this is um this is
Art thank you pleasure
Christ almighty if they taste as good as
they look they're going back on the menu
they're to die for they are [__]
delicious
[Music]
who needs a wine list when you get
pissed on the dessert
it's the day of the relaunch as well as
bringing back the Flom base I've decided
to resurrect the Gondola's Dance Floor a
house band is booked and the waiting
star finally looked apart
there will be 70 covers in tonight
double the numbers of diners that we had
in for the business lunch
it's a real test for the kitchen they're
really gonna have to pull together if
they want to carry it off
I've put Danny in charge of a staff
dinner they don't normally have them
here but they're a great way to build
teams have you got most important thing
about starting a big boys clearing out
the fridge yes okay we've got to move
now big boy we've got 10 minutes to get
this ready yes
Steve I think you could really take his
uh his own little sort of world there
doing these stuff and she's in that you
know that we're giving that little vote
of confidence yeah why not
unfortunately Steve doesn't seem very
confident with only an hour until the
first guests arrive I'm worried you're
running around getting all your plates
and bits and balls but I saw that a week
ago you're all boxed off no I was
intended to go around in the mall and
just make sure everybody knows what's
what's going on tonight and what I need
and when I show up for it what I want
yeah it's all very well it's in your
mind but the problem is I've got to talk
to them now sort of you know yeah
offloading it and get them to understand
sure yeah sure there's a feeling there
but I'm not sure if it's nervousness or
not I get stressed as much as anybody
else I'm on here I'm only human so
maybe I get stressed more than anybody
else I don't know
it's gorgeous congratulations Daniel
that's really good
see if you're not easy
well I've got two meals just since last
Friday you've had two meals since last
Friday you know just offered at the
moment
thank you I'm really worried about Steve
he seems very very nervous
the menus we've got
yep everything is in place and Ready To
Roll But at the last minute Steve
bottles it
right listen I'm running a hot plate
tonight shouldn't really be running the
hot blade but Steve's asked if I'd run
the hot plate to make sure that we get
up to speed yeah communication
chemistry understanding yeah working for
each other yeah Gareth yep what we're
gonna do tonight if we get flustered and
frustrated we're gonna do ask for help
yeah and take it out on your what pasta
that's right check out your pasta not
Daniella enjoy it
smile I'll be behind you every ounce of
the way smile
[Applause]
order on one told Lenny one part of my
hand with figs one antipasto one
linguine main course one gnocchi one
tuna one salmon one lamb
not one [__] answer yes chef
yeah thank you good boy I shouldn't be
doing this Steve needs to be able to run
his kitchen properly himself so I'm only
going to get him started so three
minutes on the hotline
Steve tomorrow you're on your own and I
just wish that you implemented a system
like this 10 years ago before you know
that I do so we'll be soaking [__]
hard now at the age of 51. yeah
thank you 14. go
right Gareth watch the cooking on the
pasta please yeah next time I'm gonna be
down on your bottle two lamb one ribeye
one two yeah sure yeah nicely put on
that plate nicely as if you're in love
with it yeah fresh turret on the top
come on how does it feel to be cooking
normally
no no different yeah no no no no no no
no it's exciting once we get this in the
system it'll be good yeah it's the only
way Steve yeah yeah I can stay here and
run this yeah but you're [__] benefit
in Jack's [__] mate yeah you're gonna
have to do it yourself now you know that
yep run your kitchen and run your team
for sure okay and if I hear you silent
I'm not talking to them yeah
up your ass it's a big one yeah [__]
right
this time in 15 years Martin's back
cooking up a storm with the flombe
good music efficient and stylish table
service at last Le Gondola is swinging
again
Freeland two Ribeyes one tuner
Anna can you send your honor in please
don't understand what all these arrows
mean so two medium one all done not to
medium is that for sure
your first main course is three lamb
they've been started doing the starters
yet okay
thank you
[Music]
as the atmosphere in the restaurant Hots
up the kitchen is going into slow motion
no
cross it off
what about that other table of four here
two Revival tuna one salmon
red eggs
all right tuners when the kitchen does
get the food out it's going down a treat
I've never seen a lady clean a plate so
quicker on my life
it's like taking a portable dishwasher
out for dinner
really really nice to enjoy authentic
Italian food very nice if they if they
stand up to the reputation that they're
set tonight we'll come back
[Music]
the new menu has been a success but
since I handed him the hot plate Steve
struggled and he's only got through it
by the skin of his teeth
come on Steve last table [__] you know
right Garrett
come in here Danny turn off the stoves
right how is that for you truthfully
could have been better ah could have
been better
smoother more communication yeah yeah
who can that communication come from
Steve meet
Hallelujah
[Music]
it's been a bloody hard week but I think
we've shown the staff that the old
Gondola has life in her yet
[__] hell two thousand pound in one
night the restaurant alone last week
took 500 quid
now there's the insight to what this
place is capable of doing and it's only
down to one thing
what is it Steve
hard work
that's all hard work
[Music]
this kitchen was so far behind the times
even I considered throwing the towel in
we struggled through a birthy function
and then a business lunch but the dinner
dance showed how the gondola can get the
good times back
I've implemented a new menu and a new
ethos in the kitchen but can they really
build on the momentum when I'm not there
to hold their hands
boiling water Danny The Apprentice does
have the makings of a good Chef you've
seen over the week that you can cook in
the star food it's a really nice thing
for you to do once a day huh I said to
me of this that I want to cook I don't
want to be like stuck on Pops in that no
you're too good for that gath also has a
chance of making it if he Knuckles down
you've left me more stuff than he has in
for years really there's someone deep
down inside there that's tucked away
that's dying to learn what wants to come
out so [__] get it out
but Steve still worries me
I think you [__] forgotten the word
cooking passion exciting yeah and you're
so right it's been switched out for a
long time it's all been
rusted up it's unless we loosened the
note it's it's just going to keep on
loosening up now I think I'm not gonna
quit on it
I'm gonna give him a [__] best
you never don't come back
[__] me I'll be back you come back
whether or not you'll be here when I get
back will be a different matter
[Music]
last summer I spent a week at La Gondola
in Derby my most testing kitchen
nightmare a restaurant 30 years out of
date it's like stepping back in time it
is and I wondered whether should we
really decorate it or wait till the
fashion turns no customers
it has a [__] reputation
[Music]
and one of the worst head chefs I've
ever met
for a 51 year old Chef to produce that
part of [__] I'm [__] gobsmacked but
somehow I managed to get the place
swinging again
four months later I'm back
and someone's in the gondola who on
Earth is that in there
oh
how are you
fine good quick kiss what's the matter
well I'd have done my hair I'd have got
changed you don't need to do that for me
Steve
he's obviously getting ready for dinner
Steve left he walked out he walked out
gave me a week's notice as soon as you
left the minute I left he walked out we
didn't have the energy thought about it
and he was out of here I didn't have the
energy I begged him to stay but he said
no his mind was made up I think he's got
a job in a pub now job in a pub yes so
what kind of food
well what the general manager calls ding
ding food you put in a microwave an
article yeah in a way I'm not that
obsessed because if he wasn't prepared
to put on the rope and actually help get
the place back
who's in there now who's the chef oh you
have to see this man saved my life hello
Wayne how are you I'm not too bad at all
Gordon nice to see you excellent so the
style of the menu what is the style of
the menu
um style a menu but not I've only
arrived yesterday okay so um
we've had no Chef since no no I did
experiment with at least four other
chefs I went through one who was feng
shui who would only copy in a certain
way yeah even Wayne's pissing himself I
did research around because it turns out
Daniela Road tested several head chefs
after Steve jumped ship at least she's
trying not to make the same mistake
twice Friday we had about 20 years with
Gareth he's still here no uh well he
finished up uh yesterday she's been
poached by Steve to go and work in a pub
when he can work here
but the money was too much of a
Temptation I'm afraid yeah that's
shocking I'm pissed off that Gaff didn't
stick it out but I think a clean slate
is the only way forward for Daniela yeah
and someone was trying to constantly
pull constantly pulling the wall over
this woman's eyes absolutely and
unfortunately because she was so nice
and so gentle everybody was taking a
piss out of her and he's becoming a
laughing stock absolutely now she's got
the bull by the horns she shook it and
she got rid of the [__] cobwebs
please tell me Danny's here he's working
tonight he's working tonight okay uh
Danny have you missed me yes I miss you
too as well you know that big man yeah
huh yes big man
little [__]
Danny's responded to my encouragement
I've taken up new responsibilities
Daniel can you get the cream please
Daniel
perhaps he and Wayne are the dynamic duo
that will give La Gambler the stability
that it desperately needs at the bottom
shelf basil uh in the package yeah
quickest account please but the proof in
the tasting
I'm having Wayne's butternut squash soup
I hope it's better than Steve's packet
minestrone
a really nice color that smells amazing
and um
it's nice it's not difficult to make but
very simple homemade rustic soup
but it you know this big volume is about
restaurant
they've built on the live music theme
Martin's still got his old magic and
he's now flombaying main courses as well
as desserts
it looks fantastic yep you sound
brilliant and it smells amazing yep you
actually taste it my very own Steak
Diane and
stays nice and round the taste is
exactly how it should be very good
Daniella's retained my simpler more
contemporary menu and they're cooking
with fresh ingredients rather than
opening a tin or a packet and the takins
have quadrupled for Zora's last here
that was lovely and I'm here really
pleased it was lovely and you've got the
simplest things right well you've made
me feel very brave about it and I just
needed someone to open my eyes up to
what streams and what's reality thank
God she's woken up she thought she'd
brought success she'd bought a
restaurant full of baggage and a chef
that didn't give a [__] now she's got
the basics right she moves forward and
this place does have a chance of
surviving for the next 30 Years
providing they continue good food good
service bit of atmosphere and enjoy what
you're doing it's not difficult
[Music]
foreign